all right let's get into the one story
that has been most requested over the
last 24 hours donald trump was
interviewed by piers morgan
trump is soaking wet i mean just
dripping dripping with sweat looks like
a rotisserie chicken i don't he almost
looks like he's been seasoned with
paprika and put under a broiler
um
in a promo released by the piers morgan
show
it looks like trump explodes ends the
interview abruptly and walks out let's
take a look at this this is a 30-second
preview of a forthcoming interview with
the failed former president okay piers
i'm ready a former president in denial
i'll be completely strengthened to your
face i think i'm a very honest man much
more honest than you actually really
yeah it was a freedom
he lost only a four would think are you
comfortable i do now yeah excuse me
excuse me the most explosive interview
of the year i don't think you're real
i'm not like very decent let's finish up
the interview morgan versus turn the
camera off
so certainly from that this looks like
the interview of the year i mean it's
it's hard to imagine anything more
explosive and comical trump dripping
with sweat disheveled
uh telling peers that he's dishonest and
peers telling him this that it looks
absolutely crazy it looks fascinating
the problem is that
there is now the claim being made and
we're still trying to figure out the
truth of it that that promo is so
deceptively edited that the true nature
of the interview is completely different
that it was there were contentious
moments but it didn't end on that note
that the interview went over by like 40
minutes from the 20 minutes it was
supposed to be
and that mostly they got along so nbc
now has put out an article which says
trump releases audio that appears to
refute the claim that he walked out of
the interview over 2020 questions
um an audio recording obtained by nbc
news appears to show that trump's highly
publicized interview with piers morgan
didn't end with trump storming off the
set as edited promotional video clips
suggest instead according to the
recording which was provided by trump's
spokesman the two men thanked each other
and laughed at the conclusion of the
interview for talk tv a subsidiary of
rupert murdoch's news corporation
talk tv is set to debut monday it teased
the interview billed as the most
explosive interview of the year in a
video summary dramatized with cinematic
music it portrays trump as being angry
about the content of the questions turn
the camera off very dishonest but the
audio at the end of the interview
appears to tell a different story the
two men laughed and thanked each other
the recording shows there are no signs
of trump storming offset
that was a great interview morgan says
trump agrees yeah thank you very much i
really appreciate it morgan says trump
then turns and says turn the camera off
but by then trump was already up from
his chair so what is the truth here i
genuinely don't know i genuinely don't
know uh i'm interested in the interview
regardless to be perfectly frank my
opinion of piers morgan is barely higher
than that of trump's i think
either is capable of extraordinary
dishonesty and the interview as as
promoted it seems almost satirical but i
don't know the truth of that and we'll
have to see it in the full interview
what it appears is that little what
might have been done is controversial
bits from the middle
were edited together to make that seem
like the end
and we're just gonna have to wait and
see now i don't let them fight amongst
each other i i i don't trust either of
them as far as they can throw them in
fact this is kind of a funny story this
new show that piers is doing on talk tv
which is part of news corporation it's
owned by rupert murdoch who owns fox and
news corporation um they've been bugging
me to appear on that show but here's the
incredible thing
the producers of this new piers morgan
show i don't know if i should be saying
this i don't really care i that they can
hate me they started contacting me
saying hey david
we think you would be a great guest for
piers morgan's new show
okay that sounds interesting sounds like
a publicity opportunity we would love
for you to participate in some
rehearsals for the show
okay i mean
taking time out of my day to appear on
something that's not even going to be
broadcast i don't know but i guess if
like if it gets me in front of peers and
i get to know him and that could still
be worth it yeah and here's the thing
it's going to be a rehearsal without
peers it's going to be really like a
tech rehearsal for the producers and the
engineers and everybody to like get used
to running the graphics and the music so
it wouldn't air and it wouldn't be with
peers it would just be like a stand-in
like okay but but listen if you get on
our good side we'll we'll have you on
the show you know as a guest when all
right i guess i'm willing to do it if i
just have to you know sit in front of
skype in my in my studio for a few
minutes they go well actually we need
you to go to a studio across the city
guys i can't do i'm sorry i'm sorry and
this is how they dangle in front of you
and i
eight years ago with other channels i
won't say which ones i fell for this
oh yeah please take time out of your day
to travel to a studio for a rehearsal
without even the host
and then we'll have you on all the time
and then they never do
i'm all set guys
okay uh everything about the production
of this show seems
teeter-tottering so it wouldn't shock me
if piers morgan deceptively edited this
and if that's the case then he deserves
uh
what whatever is coming to him now that
being said
it is not uncommon for trump to walk out
of interviews because he doesn't like
the questions it's actually a classic
authoritarian move
you claim that just real tough
interviews are unfair and then you bail
and then you use that to justify only
speaking to people in unopposed rallies
where you just lie lie lie and nobody
can oppose what you say that's a classic
mussolini move
you can read about that in history and
trump has actually done it before
remember he did it with leslie stahl on
60 minutes you're a president excuse me
leslie you started with me
your first statement was
are you ready for tough questions
are you that's no way to talk
there's no way to talk leslie
at this point one of our producers
interrupted to advise about the time
remaining in the interview
i think we have enough of an interview
here hope okay that's enough let's go
let's go
let's go meet for two seconds okay
thanks i'll see you in a little while
thanks
there's that one he also did it during a
phone interview with npr's steve inskeep
when he started getting they weren't
even really like tough questions they
were just
substantive questions trump didn't like
it and hung up the phone remember this
one i wonder the only way it's not going
to happen again
is you have to solve the problem of the
presidential rigged election of 2020. mr
president
one more question i want to ask about a
court hearing yesterday on january 6th
judge amit mehta he's gone okay
so
the peers morgan interview maybe it was
doctored maybe it wasn't we're going to
eventually find out but in all
seriousness trump's inability to truly
be questioned in a serious and detailed
manner by journalists and interviewers
it's probably part of why the republican
national committee has pulled out of
presidential debates my view is let
everybody devour each other doctored or
not whatever
give trump the toughest interviews you
can if you doctored the video
you should get devoured by the press
these are all terrible people i'm
talking about trump here and piers
morgan
and uh i think sunday or maybe it's next
week we'll find out
the full scope of what happened in that
trump piers morgan interview if you're
listening today and you want to see the
clip that we played from that interview
just go to our instagram david pakman
show we'll have it there
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house
if you don't love it but i know you will
all of my viewers will get up to 200 off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video